hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today we have some information to talk
about of the new event going live the
Jean whose gambit going live from today
December 19th up until January 2nd so it
was always like to be if you do enjoy
subscriber free new I covered the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates the Patchett's and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out and an
update if I stay subscribed to the
channel my Twitter and disco to be in
the description down below and let's get
started with today's video so first oh
it's our sponsor for today's video
raid shadow legends a turn-based RPG on
mobile with over 400 champions for you
to collect and personally customized
it's ranked top 3 in the Google Play
Store and has just been nominated as a
finalist for Google play's best of 2019
users Choice Award the game has got over
15 million downloads in just the last 6
months you can enjoy it fully boi story
campaign with over 13 locations to go to
or battle it out in the PvP arena all
for free they just added some cool new
features like auto battles which makes
you set your game to run in auto mode
while you go do something else like
grinding this new for honor content that
we're gonna be getting into later in the
video as well as weekly tournaments and
events that include fighting in the
arena
running specialized dungeons or just
leveling up your heroes they actually
have huge plans for the game detailed in
a very giant roadmap which spans over 6
months so there's an infinite amount of
content for you to enjoy and no time to
get bored this includes a new faction a
tag team arena feature and even a new
clan boss which will be able to fight
with with your other client mates you
can find me in the game one of the
nickname gin gy T and if you're quick
enough you can also join my client and
maybe find me in the PvP arena but
honestly me and my skull sworn will
probably clap you so what are you
waiting for go to the video description
click on the special link and you'll get
50,000 silver and a free epic champion
as part of the new player program to
start your journey thank you reach at
Legends for sponsoring today's video
good luck and hopefully I'll see you
guys there now that the ad is over we
can finally get into the news for today
and like I said DS on who's gambit is
the new event for season 4 year 3 or
season 12 however you want to call it
but first in the show they recap
basically what has been happening with
the year for announcements if you do
want to see that year 4 and
it'll be in the top right click the I I
covered everything about that there's
two videos that you should watch on that
and also mentioned that the testing
grounds will be used a lot more
throughout that year and maybe even used
on some game modes so here's hoping that
tribute somehow gets put into the
testing grounds and people actually play
tribute it's been way too long on top of
that if your trials rising fan I'm a big
Charles fan I just haven't played rising
sadly there is a DLC pack where you can
now actually get Rader as one of the
characters so if you want to go get
Rader and Charles rising definitely go
do that now
as you guys have been seeing from the
stuff in the trailer in the background
we're getting new emotes new commander
new illustrious outfits a lot more in
the trailer so let's get started on what
that is so like I said the DLC comes out
December 19th which is today and ends
January 2nd so roughly I think about 2
to 3 weeks I believe that's correct one
of those two numbers is correct for the
story though soon dot in the Emperor
were attacked at kiyong past which is
the new breach map for the Wulin they
were attacked by the Blackstone Legion
soon died used his experiment the
weapons of fire and burned most of the
Blackstone Legion but also took away
most of the Wulin soldiers but
apparently while the Wulin died
apparently the Blackstone Legion didn't
die and were actually cursed warriors I
believe this is really just what
happened this was just a giant war
between the Blackstone Legion and the
woobin this really had nothing to do
like this experimental fire stuff may
have occurred but these curses soldiers
is just old folklore to kind of spice up
the story a little bit this didn't
actually happen there is a new arcade
quest called the fallout for the event
that's going to be probably within the
first week and then next week that's
going to be you know a totally different
one so look out for multiple bits of new
concept from arcade there on top of that
there's a new faction event order for a
new symbol if you want to wear that with
on your characters we have a very unique
main menu with soon dot in it doing a
bunch of sword styles and stuff in the
background this image is actually
apparently pretty long so that
background keeps going it doesn't just
clip in loop like how I'm showing it in
the video cuz they only wanted to show
us small part I'm assuming that loops
perfectly and doesn't make it look a
little bit weird but it is pretty long
so definitely check that out when you
hop into the game and the black stone
legion of course like I said confirmed
to be part
the event which we talked about that
doesn't mean that they're not going to
be part of year four but they were just
kind of mentioned this whole teaser
stuff was leading up to this event
minions all sonar now Ashe minions
because of you know for the lore all
about a lota Ashe was everywhere
people's bodies burning everywhere
buildings burning everywhere the minions
are covered in ash this time and the
emblem is actually really sick I got to
admit I believe it's the outline is what
it's called and you get that by logging
in it is actually pretty fire on top of
that the new game mode is called
Emperor's escape and this one is a
little bit different from what we're
used to it is using the new map chiong
pass but it is a horde mode for player
co-op PvE mode you need to protect the
Emperor and escape chiong pass and at
least one person must survive and the
Emperor survives to win the game it's
been a long time since we had a PvE mode
I believe the last one we had was in
season five tester metal so this is
going to be really interesting the main
objective is that you capture zones to
move forward and progress with
everything else it's technically
inverted since you essentially start at
the commander phase and then end at the
beginning just like a reverse breach map
the emperor stays protected in the past
zone that you collected so don't worry
he's not going to just be up in
everybody's asses trying to kill
everyone but you can be attacked from
all sides so he can still be attacked so
you must guard him from the back as you
can see from the gameplay of what it
looks like there's of course a lot more
gameplay being shown but this is only a
teaser they don't want to spoil
everything also the enemies do not stop
responding so executions are insanely
useful or if you have a character that
has feats
I believe JJ has a couple healing feats
that would be perfect when you cap an
objective it kills all the enemies rough
looped in the area and gives a little
bit of health nothing is random though
so you know exactly what you're facing
every time you enter it so definitely
try to plan around that and essentially
for a quick recap of the rules capturing
a zone will revive all dead players and
if all players or the Emperor dies it is
game over the more you progress the
higher the difficulty eventually cursed
enemies do come in and they have special
modifiers kind of like arcade BOTS
here's a look at that new map as well
why discuss this and the arcade BOTS do
aren't weren't shown actually in the
gameplay they don't want to spoil all
that stuff but at the top right it did
say stuff about like 1 to 6 capture zone
so I'm assuming for 3
six is probably gonna have some cursed
enemies in there oh yeah like I said
this is gonna be the new map the first
fire tower was the tower that was in the
teaser it's pretty much all gone now
blown to smithereens things too soon
does fire experiment it looks like a
wasteland and I honestly love it
the atmosphere really gives off this
feeling that you're completely alone
surrounded by enemies and are basically
it's all going to [ __ ] honestly and I'm
a big fan of the PvE stuff so this is
going to be a very fun mode but we ain't
done yet we obviously got cosmetics to
talk about so we have a few lootable
things like the galilei's ultimate
effect which is it and of course the
execution emote and idol and if trends
continue you must get all three to
complete the set if you do want one that
you could just get one but whenever you
get them in game it'll usually say like
anusha effects or something like that
that pretty that doesn't mean you get
all three it means you either get the
execution the emote or the idol you have
to get all three if you want to get all
three there's also going to be new
ornaments that are faction based which
means that they change based on the
faction that you are and they aren't all
the same ornament and it kind of makes
it look like [ __ ] so that's pretty cool
to look at I do like the designs on
these this is also a new battle outfit
as well just like we get every event and
the one thing that you're probably the
most hyped about is the two illustrious
outfits that we will be getting each
priced at 20,000 and it's like a
two-person thing that we had last year
with in with that Halloween event where
it's like the two factions going up
against each other like the ghouls and
the vampires and like the werewolf type
thing that's kind of what we have now so
we have the soon das game bit which is
essentially a floating horse in the
chieng embassy which it looks [ __ ]
sick as well kind of nice little helmet
so if that ends up not clipping through
your helmet I definitely go grab that
but anyway I'm going to definitely be
grabbing the horse because I think it
looks really cool that of course comes
an idol emo and execution you'll be
getting the effects for all three of
them honestly the executioner for the
horse has got to be my favorite imagine
getting smoked so bad that a horse pulls
up shrugs at you and runs off like what
kind of disrespect is that also a new
emote which is gonna be priced at 10,000
steel which was in the trailer that we
saw it's called zon who is fire and then
of course we're gonna be getting the
bundle for the illustrious outfits emo
battle outfit effect an ornament and
that's all going to be priced at 45,000
you're gonna get everything we talked
about for 45 case steel and the price
goes down based on what you want
macht it's going to be per character so
you have to pay 45 K for GLAAD 45 K for
warlord and you got to keep doing that
for every character so please be aware
on that so I do recommend always
grinding first throughout the event and
then right before it ends I would buy
the pack so that you have the lowest
amount of money possible spent and you
get all the good rewards as always we
got new weapons I'm a big fan of purple
so this is gonna be a really dope event
for me so starting out for the nights we
have warden PK Centurion and gladiator
law bringer conquer and BP in that order
as they go along on the screen just
wanted to update you guys or any new
players that have no idea who the
characters are I wanted to let you guys
know what weapons correspond to what in
the video but that's gonna be the order
as you can see there's lots of purple
and some silver to match the event so
that might go well with some characters
they tried to tie it into the lore as
much as possible they actually end up
giving conker and BP a Pegasus shield
which is pretty nice
I definitely not a bit like I'm not a BP
guy I'm not a [ __ ] guy but if you're one
of those people I definitely pick up
this Pegasus shield it's one of the
cooler looking shields that I know those
characters have gotten especially
because they have so much room to work
with they can have a bunch of different
things go on that shield it just looks
crazy any shield characters any of you
guys that play shield characters during
this event are gonna be very happy
next up we have the Vikings which is
Raider Berserker Highlander shaman
valkyrie warlord and ending with your
man Gunther so lots of forces on these
weapons I believe they were talking this
was based off the Celtic folklore I
believe what they said was like that
this specific horse can turn into a
human I'm not really well-versed in
Celtic folklore and I may have said some
things wrong but just know that the
Viking weapons are very lore based so
this does just historically accurately
go well with the weapons so it looks
really cool a lot of purple and [ __ ]
warlords is definitely crazy
good-looking like I said you're a
warlord player you're a conch player
you're a BP player pick up these shield
weapons even if you don't get the weapon
part and you just want the shield pick
up the shield even if you're never gonna
use it just please get it it's so damn
good
warlord players rejoice though because
that's a really nice welcomed weapon
for the samurai we have Ken say Orochi
shinobi are amou Shinobu she shoe go key
ending with hito kiri for this nothing
was said much on the samurai they were
just kind of showing off how beautiful
these things looked our Musa has a nice
blue and gold look finished with the
inning yank and of style that he always
goes for so I'm always a big fan of our
mushas weapons and this is just gonna be
added to the list of many of the
beautiful weapons that he has in his
arsenal
and then lastly to end it we have the
woobin which is T on D Xiaolin noushad
JJ and soon de I love new shoes weapons
actually the little pink and purple it's
not this purple and blue stuff for the
golden blue like our Musha it's this
little pink and purple and I'm
definitely [ __ ] with that definitely
have to pick that up for new shoes since
I'm playing or just a little bit just
kind of having a little bit of fun with
her
soon dies is absolutely deadly and I am
100% getting his weapon as well and of
course remembered that these weapons are
lootable throughout all games that you
play as well as scavenger crates you
just have to play that that specific
character we're gonna be going over a
recap at about two seconds but just to
know that the weapons are for the
specific character now that that juicy
stuff is all said and done we have to go
talk about what is what what can you pay
for what can you loot all that good
stuff so let you guys know so that you
know what you're going for the stuff
that you have to pay for is the mask
outfits that we were just talking about
as well as that new emote Jean whose
fire you have to pay for those
you cannot unlock these in-game anything
like that you'll have to pay for them
either separately or through the bundle
the rest of the stuff which is the
weapons the effect the galilei's
ultimate effect the ornament the battle
outfit though that type of stuff that is
completely lootable throughout games and
you can do that whenever you want just
that you know any time you're playing
the game you might get one of those I'll
come out with a video in little letting
you know in the near future talking
about that stuff as usual but for the
weapons specifically just keep in mind
for the weapons it has to be for the
character you're playing so for the
battle outfit the effect the ornament
that doesn't matter who you're playing
that just kind of comes randomly so you
could be playing our Musha and you get
like t on DS or something that's usually
how it happens but for the weapons it
has to be for the character that you
want to get it for so if you want to get
the Highlander weapon got to play
Highlander want the warlord weapon got
to play warlord that's the rules for
that just wanted to keep you guys up to
date on what's going on with that stuff
and yeah guys that's really about it
like the video if you do enjoy let me
know what you guys think about this
stuff in the comments below I'm super
excited to go hop into this new event I
got a few other videos that I need to
take care of for today so I'm definitely
gonna be on the lower end probably gonna
be hopping in later tonight but yeah let
me know how you guys are enjoying the
event if it's out by the time that
you're watching this video if you've
already played it or just your thoughts
on this stuff in the comments but
it's been a very very long time since we
had a PvE mode and I love PvE stuff as I
said season 5 one of the best seasons
we've ever had so I'm super excited to
finally go back into playing a PvE mode
and it the atmosphere and they just rock
every single time this is the second PvE
mode I think we've gotten in this game
and I guarantee you it's just gonna slap
it's gonna be amazing they might have
been updated weekly that'll be sick I'll
let you guys know about that in a future
video
yeah like 2v if you do enjoy guys
subscribe before new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes in the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening then the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update don't we subscribe to the channel
or that guys take her have a greatest ur
day peace out and enjoy the event
you